and then you try to locations to shame
me huh know what I just said was the
question are you shocked at the
condition in which we live no I think I
wish how you do my pockets on my house
you know what I think is cuz this is a
successful showing I think that you guys
do it hot over here which you Johnny
star doing going to studios and stuff
like that which I know I'm saying it's
cool they just know I didn't know
they're like Bob Bobby's just waking up
so kind of pipe down when he sleeps
[Laughter]
yeah no idea I'm like oh he slept he was
working all night so he slept in the
studio I like the work people sleep here
at night almost like almost out in here
no you I like your following and again
like the fun like funky cool in a good
way thank you
[ __ ] ass your deceiver good way you
know you're a trickster do so how many
people live here total human trafficking
business or anything no it's a week we
live here with six animals and then when
her like you know island kook relatives
come to visit the nine of them ten of
them sitting here that's good and they
make stuff
[Music]